[Musique]
la responsabilité qui vous a été confié
n'est pas de gouverner contre le peuple
le pays est sans dessus dessous et ce
n'est pas le moindre des problèmes de ne
plus trouver de sens il traverse une
crise politique qui n'est pas sans
conséquences sociales et économiques et
vous en êtes comptable vous ne vous en
tirerez pas avec un passage en force ni
dans le pays ni ici au parlement nabih
mais pas plus notre république et la
démocratie
ne cédez pas à la tentation de pyrrhus
ne déposez pas ce projet vendredi jouer
l'apaisement
sortez par le haut de cette situation
bloquée la seule solution raisonnable et
de retirer votre projet et d'engager une
véritable discussion vouloir bloquer un
certain nombre de sites ne pas respecter
la loi
en s'introduisant dans telle ou telle
enceinte privée procéder à des coupures
sauvages de courant tout cela
tout cela c'est méconnaître la
démocratie tout cela c'est méconnaître
la loi et tout cela doit être sanctionné
car ça n'est pas acceptable ça n'est pas
acceptable monsieur le député vous le
savez parfaitement l'outil de production
ils se respectent
le service public ils se respectent nos
concitoyens ils se respectent
lorsqu'on possède à des grèves lorsqu'on
procède par don à des coupures sauvages
d'électricité ont met nécessairement nos
concitoyens les usagers du service
public dans une situation qui est
parfois périlleuses et ça n'est pas
acceptable
concrètement l'ensemble des personnels
doivent faire face à l'accumulation de
nouvelles tâches sans que ne soit
reconnu clairement les temps nécessaire
à l'organisation du nouveau bac dans
certains établissements la mise en
oeuvre de la dématérialisation des
supports pose de gros problèmes
les notes des épreuves de contrôle
continu ne figureront pas sur les
bulletins
elles sont donc des épreuves anticipées
du bac leur harmonisation et leur
correction mérite donc une juste
reconnaissance
pourquoi vous entêtez vous monsieur le
ministre a considéré que ceux qui
critiquent votre réforme en forcément
tort ecalle inverse de vous il n'aurait
pas le souci de leurs élèves ou le sens
des responsabilités les équipes vous
demande une liberté pédagogique des
décharges et des indemnités des
créations de postes la formation et
l'accompagnement à ces réformes
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui perturbe les
épreuves prennent une responsabilité
très grave vis-à-vis des élèves il y a
eu des choses scandaleuses ces derniers
jours samedi dans l'académie d'auvergne
plusieurs lycées ont composé de manière
totalement normal ce qui prouve que
quand on fait les choses normalement
tout se passe normalement
un seul lycée a fait l'objet de
perturbations c'est celui dans les
médias ont parlé évidemment les
perturbations sont le fait d'éléments
notamment extérieure c'est de
l'intrusion c'est illégal
quand on est pour la république on est
contre ce genre d'action est tout
simplement en a le droit d'être contre
une réforme
simplement on ne peut pas dire qu'il a
pas eu de concertation et on ne peut pas
dire que les choses ne sont pas faites
dans les règles de l'état de droit
aujourd'hui l'état de droit c'est ce que
nous faisons les violations de l'état de
droit
c'est ce que vous semblez soutenir
monsieur ministre depuis quelques jours
pointent une vaine polémique initiée par
les oppositions qui commence à s'agiter
et qui ne sont pas avares d'adjectifs
pour qualifier ce texte administratif
elle en oublie par là même que ce sont
les femmes et les hommes qui habitent
dans les communes concernées qui
choisissent les maires et les élus
municipaux en toute connaissance de
cause et non pas pour suivre les
injonctions de tel ou tel parti
politique cela même mes chers collègues
qui se sont succédé au pouvoir ces
dernières décennies avec les résultats
que l'on sait aussi monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur pourriez vous rappeler à
la représentation nationale les
motivations les origines et les
objectifs de la circulaire je crois
utile de rappeler qu'à l'entier soutien
de l'association des maires de france et
des maires ruraux je vous remercie
il est important de savoir ce dont on
parle d'abord jouets rétablir une vérité
que chaque candidat pourra librement
comme à chaque élection décider de son
étiquette politique et affirmer son
étiquette politique et je le dis ici
devant vous moi qui suis un élu de la
ruralité
il n'y a pas de petites communes avec
des petits élus
[Musique]